This next material is bonus. It's optional but it's really cool and it will
only take a few minutes to go through. So far we've only used one predictor
variable. In the case before, the predictor was the distance traveled, and we
were using that to predict the flight cost. But often times there are many
factors that can predict the dependent variable. When we use multiple
predictors, we're doing multiple regression. The purpose is to explain more of
the variation in y. Basically we regress y on predictor 1, predictor 2, all the
way to however many predictors we want. Why don't we do a simple linear
regression for each one? The reason we just have one equation is not only
because it's easier but also because when we include several predictors, we can
calculate the relationship that each predictor has with y independently of the
other predictors. For example, in my master's thesis, I wanted to look at
things that impact student effort in math class. Remember that effort is the
construct. So I measured this by things like whether or not they did their
homework and time spent studying. A lot of things can influence effort.
Specifically, I was interested in how much students value mathematics. Did they
believe that math will help them in their careers? And also how much they enjoy
math class. And their relationship with their teachers. It's possible that
having a good relationship with their teachers can make them enjoy school more.
And if they enjoy school more, they'll put forth more effort. Or maybe students
place value on subjects that they enjoy. When we include all of these as
predictors we no longer have a simple slope. Instead we get regression
coefficients for each predictor variable. These will be numbers. Just like how
before when we had one variable we found the slope and that was our regression
coefficient. In this case we'll have three. These coefficients tell us the rate
of change in y, given a one unit change in each respective variable holding the
others constant. In other words we see the mathematical influence of one
variable while statistically controlling for the influence of the other
variables. We could go into more details but we won't. Multiple regression is
not usually covered in elementary statistics courses. But it's still valuable
to know about, and be able to interpret. Apart from the regression
coefficients, most programs that conduct multiple regression will also provide
a multiple correlation coefficient called r. This is similar to interpretation
to Pierson's r. But it involves one outcome or response variable and more than
one predictor variable. This tells us the strength of the relationship between
y and the combined set of predictors. Usually we're more interested in r
squared, which tells us the proportion of variability in y explained by our set
of predictors.